in the small clutch of circumstance I
have not winced nor cried aloud under
the bludgeonings of chance my head is
bloody but unbowed beyond this place of
Wrath and tears looms the horror of the
shade and yet the Menace of the years
Finds Me unafraid
Mr wives star Christine Brown shares a
passionate message amid the news her
former sister wife Janelle split from
Cody I'm super close with Chanel that's
that's of course very different the 50
year old reality star who called it
quits with Cody last year shared this
video giving a reading of Invictus by
William Ernest Henley Christine's
hashtags I am the captain of my soul and
you have a purpose Beyond this place of
Wrath and tears looms the horror of the
shade and yet the Menace of the years
Finds Me unafraid it matters not how
straight the gate nor charged with
punishment the scroll I am the master of
my fate I am the captain of my soul the
reading came the day after news broke
Janelle's officially separated from Cody
After nearly 30 years of their spiritual
marriage Janelle has made it pretty
clear to me that she's
enjoying her life without me
I think if we both really sat down we'd
look at each other and say really we've
been separated for several months what
so are you separated yes we are
separated I think there was a lot of
challenges and it played out in
in just as complicated way in our family
as it does in the bigger sphere and if
Christine's poem really is a nod of
support for Janelle well it wouldn't
exactly be a surprise we know that
despite their splits from Cody Christine
and Janelle remain closer than ever as
far as the family goes I'm still with
half the family Janelle and her kids I
am still with them so as far as Sister
Wives go I'll still be doing things with
Janelle quite regularly but Janelle's
support for Christine after leaving
became a point of contention with Cody
this season on their TLC series at the
end of the day I think I'd rather be
with my kids well that's what
Christine's decision was it's been a bit
of a Civil War the whole family in a way
and I'm looking at Janelle wondering
whose side she's on I'm just like what
sorry I don't even recognize
this family or whatever like I
like I don't know something has really
changed for me and now as Janelle
navigates this next chapter without Cody
there's no doubt Christine will be in
her corner I don't know if she can be
Sister Wives you know if you're not
really but I just consider tell my
sister if she just always will be and so
we vacation together and we've hung out
together so we're fine together
foreign